public colleges and universities
tuition-free damn right
you're about to get out democratic free
college tuition that's still too much
money my plan is free college tuition
and we give you a twenty the most
progressive dude up here let's reread
your treatises I spoke on Wall Street
who will pile a beta0 health care free
schools free clothing free energy you go
to the post office
overnight anything this isn't rocket
science no need to act cleverly was any
easier it'd be celebrity jeopardy angry
Santa complaining maybe take a warm bath
dude you been a Democrat for like a day
and a half she learned from Ted Kennedy
I learned from him after he taught me to
drive then swim shortly thereafter voted
for the Brady Bill and dodd-frank at
first glance net from the NRA and also
in math the banks are too big they act
like casinos they do big the veil can
you grab that mosquito staying in NATO
talk about a disaster I'd rather play
twister with the sweaty Danny has
stirred my plan to beat Isis they're
gonna be running when this president
comes after him with to reset by an
super predator over here your crime
bills tough you'll be regretting them
Sentencing Guidelines in a couple of
months even my first hundred days I will
make it my mission to find my colleges
with lazy rivers of raising tuition ever
line a bathroom law that song is a sad
Tango's is the only intolerance you
should face in a bathroom sorry
you